jordan clarkson going with the the guy
who's probably going to be the sixth man
of the year that's why i put him on
there
he's been the best bench player in the
nba this year they got the best record
in the nba
you know most people don't notice that
he has been fantastic this year that's
why i got him on my list
and true to your word you did not have
anthony davis on your
on your list as well i played like an
hour this ain't lifetime achievement
award
you think you so you think that that's
not the point that's not the point we're
talking about we're having the best year
of the year we're talking about who's
having the best year
not who's a better player i didn't say
that that that doesn't
matter either it's not who's the best
player it's who's having the best year
that's how
no no no what say it again
jordan clarkson is having a great year i
wanted to reward him
okay over anthony davis yes
i'm not i mean your look says is anthony
davis a better player
is a better player yes
he's not playing anthony davis all-star
well then so what are we voting on
you can't compete you're comparing him
to himself yeah we got you got to
compare him to the field
exactly yeah and jordan clarkson's
having a better year let's